welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and the late great Tony Stark made
his Mark with Riri Williams ironheart
and black panther what kind of river
with some overt Iron Man nods with shuri
identifying the schematics as quote
Stark Tech riri's initial ascent and
fall paralleling Tony's first real
flight in the first Iron Man film and
even the signature Iron Man sound effect
hidden in riri's chest reactor
[Music]
but now with ironheart star Dominique
Thorne revealing Robert Downey Jr called
her to offer some words of wisdom I'm
thinking back on some of these Clues
from wakanda forever and what I saw in
the Iron Heart trailer in d23 and I'm
realizing it might be possible that a
Tony Stark might have actually known
Riri Williams and B the technological
Legacy that he left Peter Parker might
have been something he actually intended
Peter to share with another MIT student
that's right Santa Stark wrote on the
card that this PS5 is for you and your
sister so share share upon the
releasable kind of forever Dominique
Thorne told Screen Rant in an interview
that she spoke with Robert Downey Jr via
FaceTime when a cast made from ironheart
who had worked with Robert Downey Jr
connected the two of them now you may
have wondered who this mystery
connecting actor was and I actually
think it was Alden ehrenreich who was
reported by deadline last summer to play
some role in ironheart and would have
been filming at the same time
Christopher Nolan's upcoming Oppenheimer
film along with Robert Downey Jr and
pretty much everyone else in Hollywood
that cast is huge anyway Thorne said
Robert Downey Jr had some beautiful
words about how much he believes that
weird Williams should always be her own
person her own thing that this Legacy
has had in the right to Direction and
all the beautiful encouraging things
that you hope to hear from the Iron Man
himself such a wholesome sentiment
between actors but is this reflecting a
mentorship that could have existed
between the characters of Tony Stark and
Riri Williams in the MCU did these two
ever cross paths well if we assume that
Riri Williams did not flip yes it's not
only possible but actually likely that
Tony Stark knew who Riri was now when we
went into wakanda forever I expected
Riri Williams to be a wannabe Avenger in
the style of Kamala Khan someone
inspired by Iron Man and the other
Avengers to build their own suits but
not someone who actually knew or met the
Avengers at any point at least not at
first but then when Riri takes shuri and
okoya to a warehouse sure he observes
schematics on riri's board that shuri
identifies as Stark Tech now whether it
was proprietary information then Riri
was somehow able to acquire or Tech that
she was able to reverse engineer on her
own so well that it looked like the real
thing to shuri this means that Riri was
able to accomplish in a few years what
the world's best engineers and weapons
contractors during the Iron Man 2 era
were unable to do and what's interesting
is Tony actually did say during that
Senate testimony in Iron Man 2 that most
imitators were years away from building
their own Iron Man suits yeah I'd say uh
most countries 5-10 years away
Hammer Industries 20. aha 10 years away
ended up being roughly the amount of
time for reread to emerge on the world
stage with their own Iron Man style suit
now crucial to the possible connection
between Tony Stark and Riri Williams is
MIT this is reread's current school and
Tony Stark's alma mater now we've spoken
before how in Civil War Tony announced a
new research grant program for all MIT
students as of this moment every student
has been made an equal recipient of the
inaugural September Foundation Grant as
in
all of your projects have just been
approved in funding reframe
inaugural means that this grant is going
to get reapproved every year from there
forward so even though in 2016 Riri
probably would have been too young to be
an active MIT student at that point
still every year after that even after
Tony's death his estate likely continues
to pay for all these projects the
ironheart trailer that hasn't been
released wide yet but I was able to get
a preview look at it at d23 confirms
that Jim Rash is returning from this
scene in Civil War as an MIT
administrator so Tony's September
Foundation funding is likely to come up
in the ironheart series but there was
another interesting line from Riri in
wakanda Forever she says there's an
entire YouTube channel dedicated to
sightings of me which reminded me of how
Tony Stark was initially able to find
Peter Parker which is something I was
able to figure out in past videos Civil
War and homecoming show how amateur
footage of Peter's heroics ended up
online probably shamelessly uploaded by
Peter himself since the cameras are
always strategically placed and Tony was
able to track down Peter from there I
think there may have been a similar
Recruitment and mentorship process
between Tony and Riri Williams and why
do I think that well it all goes back to
that note that Tony left with his Edith
glasses in Spider-Man far from home now
can be hard to watch actors and not
immediately think hey I'd like to have
gorgeous skin and hair just like they do
well with geology you can geology is a
fourth time award-winning personalized
skincare company recognizing Men's
Health Esquire and ask men grooming
Awards with over 6 000 5 Star reviews
and they've recently expanded to offer
products for well pretty much whatever
you need like if you need Hair Care use
geology's co-wash it's a specially
formulated cream cleanser that removes
buildup and cleanses the hair without
the big lather or harsh ingredients of
typical shampoo and for the rest of your
shower routine you can use their body
washes they're free of harsh ingredients
smell great and are refillable and for
after the shower protect your skin from
environmental stressors with vitamin C
plus a ferrillex serum keep your skin
looking young and healthy and then a bit
of the dermatologist tested aluminum
free deodorant that quite honestly
smells great right now for a limited
time geology is hooking our audience up
with an absolutely insane offer if you
use the code new rockstars they will
give you an additional 70 off their
award-winning skincare trial set this
discount stacks on top of their current
sale prices and there's also an
additional bonus offer on one of their
brand new skin hair and body products of
your choice when you add it to your
trial with the holidays right around the
corner geology has you covered check out
their awesome gift sets featuring all of
your favorite geology products to get
started just click the link in the
description take a 30 second diagnostic
quiz and their team of dermatologists
will design a personalized routine just
for you that ships directly to your door
he wrote for the next Tony Stark I trust
you P.S say Edith signed TF and there
are two issues I've always had with
these one if Tony did not know that
Peter had come back until the middle of
the battle of Earth and in game when
would he have had time to write this
note and make these arrangements with
Edith how could Tony have arranged this
with Nick Fury when Nick Fury was also
tested during the blip another person
that Tony didn't know he'd be able to
bring back was this some kind of will
and testament contingency Tony just had
in place sure I guess you could say Tony
pre-recorded some more hologram messages
to give all these instructions
post-mortem that just would have been a
lot for him to Think Through he starts
in-game completely happy to be in
retirement it seems like they're
planning for the time ice took a couple
weeks sure maybe Tony made some
arrangements then it's just weird that
he had all this figured out for Peter
Parker someone that Tony assumed was
dead for good but the second issue is
the note itself Tony does not address it
to Peter he addresses it to the next
Tony Stark would that really be how Tony
addresses Peter I mean didn't Tony
always want Peter to be better than him
this kind of just sounds like an inside
joke Tony might have had with someone
else and yes we should also know that
this whole handoff was a weird mission
that Fury gave to the squirrel Talos and
we don't really know if we can try
address what the hell they're doing
apart from home stock left these for you
uneasy lies the head that wears the
crown Scott said you wouldn't get that
because it's not a Star Wars reference
we gave the glasses to Parker about a
week ago like he said and uh really
really quite touching now they also
set them for Peter but we don't really
likely that Tony would have had time to
made arrangements to bequeathed tattooed
Kitty had no way of knowing would be
back alive in the world to receive this
now yes you're gonna say when Peter
Parker put on those Edith glasses they
scanned his eye and it's directly
encoded to him I think it's most likely
that Tony just had an inner circle of
people where have any of them put on
these glasses either would be like okay
yeah you're in too I mean let's be real
Peter just kind of gave a voice command
to hand it off to Clinton back the
security features weren't exactly
airtight here we just have to remember
in the opening active end game from
Tony's point of view Peter was gone Tony
spent those entire five years moving on
with his life but while Tony didn't have
his Protege Peter Parker during the blip
we know Tony was busy during the blip
busier than we thought he helped Bruce
Banner build a whole gamma lab in Mexico
he spent a lot of that time drinking
talking about cap he didn't spend the
full five years kicking back on the farm
with pepper he continued working on
various projects and I think one of
those projects was to find a new Protege
to offload some of his engineering
knowledge to another bright mind that he
found on social media and hooks up with
a letter of recommendation a scholarship
to MIT and a grant the genius from
Chicago Riri Williams ironheart I think
he was the one who hooked up Riri with
authentic Stark text Dramatics that's
why her chest reactor warms up with the
same Iron Man suit sound and I really
think the Edith glasses weren't
necessarily specifically for Peter
Parker maybe if Riri had put on those
glasses she also would have been able to
command all the stark drone Fleet I
remember as Tony said to the MIT
students re-frame the future I think
Tony's ultimate Hope was that maybe
somehow his sacrifice could bring back
Peter Parker and that kid could get into
MIT where he would have an older sister
waiting for him a friend to Peter that
Roadie and Steve and Bruce were to Tony
now folks I'm not theorizing this to say
Riri couldn't have built Iron Man Tech
herself she obviously can she's
brilliant and I think that's why Tony
recruited her I'm also not theorizing
this to take anything away from Tony's
relationship with Peter I just think
Tony Stark was a lonely know-it-all and
he loved finding other smartest people
in the room to give them the tools they
need to succeed so why not give this
dead guy more friends you can follow me
on Tick Tock Instagram and Twitter and a
boss follow new Rockstar subscribe to
new Rockstar some more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye foreign
[Music]